à saint pierre des corps près de la gare
à la résidence les cas d'où vient d'être
livré dix logements sont proposés en
location accession comme ce t2 de 52
mètres carrés vendus 124 mille euros ce
dispositif permet aux revenus les plus
modestes de devenir propriétaires d'un
logement neufs bénéficiant des dernières
normes d'isolation un luxe pour la
plupart des primo accédants dans
l'ancien oui dans neuf
celui-ci mais fait pas si bien situé
peut-être une superficie plus petits
tout c'est pas je me serais tourner vers
l'ancien touraine logement voir la
formule sur conditions de ressources
inférieures à 2000 euros après une
période locative de deux ans le
locataire accèdent à la propriété
les loyers déjà payés sont déduits du
prix de vente autre avantage le prêt à
taux zéro le prêt de la métropole ou
encore l'exonération de la taxe foncière
pendant 15 ans et petit bonus le
logement avant construction et
personnalisable t personnalisé au niveau
des espaces elles sont respectées à
l'identique du plan mais c'est
personnalisé au niveau des choix de
coloris des revêtements de sols des
revêtements de faïence c'est déjà
beaucoup pour le client puisque en
général vide ne s'y attend pas c'est
toujours un plus de 100 familles ont
déjà bénéficié de ce dispositif en
touraine actuellement des logements en
location-accession sont disponibles dans
six communes d'indre et loire comme
tourneur jouer verrettes ou
cinq-mars-la-pile